hey guys i'm ryan wright and i'm taylor
bradley today we're checking out a video
called how to be
gay taylor might not know this but i
have had some of my gay experimentations
in the past
realized it wasn't for me how was that
it's cool i tried like three times i
never like sucked a dick or anything
no it just wasn't for me i'm sorry to
hear that one time i didn't know it was
a guy
oh well then you can't really be blamed
for that yeah
uh but after i found out i was a guy i
was like no let me try it okay
nah didn't work out that's fine to each
his own i just
really like vaginas and i've never felt
emotionally
pulled towards a guy you know it might
have been because of all the porn i grew
up watching not even
uh what's his face gosling yeah ryan
gosling
it's different for ryan gosling i think
a lot of guys would say that
no i've been with significantly more
women and i i
prefer women like a lot okay
well let's watch this video and see if
at the end of it you still prefer women
yeah i don't know if this is a legit
video but
i like the title who knows
what the hell
there you go
touch anger
look i it was a gay black guy for me
what
so
i don't get it i don't get it either you
guys have to tell me what's happening
because i don't get it
this is creepy this is really disturbing
i saw another one from these guys called
how to use a condom
that kind of creeped me out though what
is this
i don't know these are like weird joking
how-to videos
i i don't i don't get it i feel like
i've aged like 10 years by watching that
video
yeah i just don't get the fish part i
don't get the fish i mean i think it was
like the sound
thing why do you like lube it up to i
don't because i think the
toilet's supposed to be like justin
bieber oh and that's his ass
or something then he sticks a fish up is
it a dead
lubed-up fish i don't get it i don't get
it at all it was gross
it was do you think bieber's gay i don't
i don't know
probably not but i don't know
i don't know anything anymore right now
i just feel offended
in like my heart i'm not even gay and
i'm offended i'm offended i don't even
know why i'm offended i don't even know
either and like the pink nail polish in
the beginning was
weird at first i was like okay i get the
jokes here yeah
gay barbie dolls like i gotcha egg i
didn't understand he like dropped an egg
a few times didn't he
like twice and he like walked on the
eggshells is it like a walking on
eggshells metaphor like gay people have
to walk on eggshells in society yeah i
think a lot of it's metaphors but
i just can't figure out what the fish is
i mean i think it's just beyond us
it is i think it's too small we're just
not intellectual enough man
i'm sure you guys know can you guys
please explain below like what it
actually means
or your theories because i feel like
your theories will be just as
interesting as
real life yeah we live in california
where the gay population is really
rising and right it's really you know
coming out of the closet
it's pretty much accepted as something
normal out here but i know in other
places of america and the
in the world like it's still not
accepted right and it's still like a
shocking thing or a taboo thing i feel
like though it's
rapidly changing i'm still surprised
that people aren't okay with it
obviously because it's like at this
point you know you're on the wrong side
of history and you're still just like no
i'm gonna be a white supremacist like
who still
decides that that's a good idea yeah
there are people there are people out
there
that's what's weird it's like there was
a time where if you hated gays it was
like
normal and now when you hate gays you're
like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you
homophobic like now it's like
[ __ ] up to like not like still like
for me it's always been a major issue
because i grew up in theater you know
and i've done theater my whole life and
it's a huge part of the gay community i
feel like is theater and it's always
been a very accepting place
anyone can come here and be accepted and
be loved for who they are and so i for
as long as i can remember i've always
been
not only okay with it but it's always
been a very normal thing for me and
growing up and moving out of my town
that i grew up in and seeing that it's
not like that everywhere i kind of was
shocked actually i was like wait
why why why is it hot and okay
it's just love yeah it's it's like it
really it's
none of my business right it's like okay
two guys or two girls wanna be with each
other
sure go for it like it's not affecting
my life
never understood why anyone was upset
about it and i get like there's the
religious aspect of like people saying
what the bible says
but the bible says so many crazy things
that we don't listen to anymore but it's
like why
are we focusing on this one to be like
oh no this is what it said it's like
how long ago was the bible written it's
still imposing
your beliefs on someone else when you
say that like especially in
america where it's supposed to be
separation of church and state right
we're in a
society where it's like you can't impose
your beliefs on
someone else if these gay guys don't
believe it like
let them be when you're dealing with
faith you
you won't know for sure whether you're
100
right or 100 wrong until you're [ __ ]
dead so
like and even then you might not know
because you could just be dead
yeah you don't you don't know yeah can i
just say that i'm really impressed with
this video for sparking a really
intellectually like challenging debate
about the separation of church and state
yeah
mm-hmm so good job video good job video
made us think
it was the fish it was the fish it was
the [ __ ] fish it pushed it over the
edge the fish
and the beaver oh i never want to watch
that again though in all honesty that
was really disturbing but if you're gay
be gay
bisexual be bisexual but don't watch
this video if you're whatever just don't
watch this video and if you feel like
experimenting experiment unless you
already did i guess you technically
already watched the video
at this point and if you want to suck a
dick to try it out see what it tastes
like go for it
go for it anyway guys thanks for tuning
in if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can follow us on facebook instagram
and twitter
where if we get enough followers we can
get product placement for example
yes hold it up proudly starbucks
starbucks is great if you ever need a
pick-me-up
get some starbucks if you ever want to
take your offer
you know coffee go to starbucks if
you're ever too tired
to [ __ ] but you know your girl's down
for it go to
star [ __ ]
i see what you did there i bet they want
to sponsor me now what you did there
i saw it yeah clever yeah too clever
i think that's all we have i'm trying to
think of a gay joke but i can't come up
with one star
that was the closest we're gonna get